i believe that there is a
uh that people looking at
sort of the cliff that that were you
know that america is just hurtling
towards this cliff and about to go over
i i think an awful lot of people
protestants catholics and jews and
others
would be
willing to negotiate some kind of a
a
return of
let's say the
the basic christian moral vision to be
like the public background against which
uh things are are operate in some places
i mean in some some states in the us and
i think
the conservative way to do this is you
know not to have uh the supreme court
you know dictate this to people who
don't want it the conservative way to do
it is to experiment with it in those
places that want it so that we can see
what is this you know what does this add
up to
so do you think secular institutions
simply cannot work
at all i mean
basically what you're saying is there
well i guess everything is going to
degrade over time right
everything degrades over time the ques
the the question is are are you
helping it degrade or are you working
for a restoration where you can see that
you know a mistake has been made so you
could you can act to try to stop it look
dave i i'm i'm i'm a religious person in
the end
um i you know in the end i think uh
we have to do what looks right to us the
best we can in the end we're really bad
at seeing the future and what's going to
happen is going to you know god decides
in the end what's going to come of all
of our efforts but we have an obligation
to to try to restore things you know to
try to restore
respect for the american constitution
and the anglo-american
legal tradition we have to try to
restore respect for the traditional
family and for uh for the bible and for
god
that's up to us to try to do and you
know maybe it'll work
so i think a certain amount of people
are watching this and what they may not
know is uh on the other side of that
very fine head of hair my friend is is a
yamaka back there you are an orthodox
jew you live you live in jerusalem uh
and yet here you are talking about anglo
beliefs uh christian america things like
that uh i was on a panel with you at
natcon where we were trying to sort of
work out it was it was the two of us and
sora bamari who i've had on the show and
douglas murray who i've had on many
times trying to sort of
whittle out where if you were to go back
to some of what you're calling for in a
national conservative country
what happens to the minorities what
happens to the religious minorities what
happens to people that don't necessarily
prescribe to all of the sort of
religious set of views that you're
including here so what do we do with
that
okay well the the book deals with
two different fronts okay one one is the
question you're asking me now which is
uh about you know the public life
of
of the country and the other the other
part of the book deals with you know
with our private lives and because
people tend to think these things are
unrelated i think they're
deeply connected and so the the book is
really an argument for people to
uh to drop the idea that you can just
argue for conservative policy i i think
that you have to also lead a
conservative life you have to
come back to a conservative life and be
a conservative person so there there are
those two things now when when i talk
about conservative democracy
i'm talking about a democracy right i'm
talking about you know the kind of
democracy that uh that america was
um
sure there's some things from the past
that we should never go back to i mean
you know slavery and persecution of uh
blacks in america just as like the most
obvious example i i don't know any
conservative that wants to go back to
that in fact the in my book i make the
argument that that was a
deviation from the anglo-american
tradition which is you know for a very
long time was anti-slavery before there
were slaves in america
but um but since i'm arguing for
democracy i'm i'm still talking about
the the political framework
where this should not be imposed on
anybody we're talking about um
those states that still have a christian
majority you know or let's say i mean
maybe there's uh orthodox jews who would
uh support this kind of thing uh or
others so those those states those
regions those places
where there's still a desire to lead a
a democratic life but where the public
the the the public philosophy let's say
is is not neo-marxism the public
philosophy is going to be based on a
biblical vision on a on a christian and
and and jewish vision
and i'm my my assumption is that um that
anybody who actually
wants to do this i'm not just assuming
it i mean this is what i you know i i
i talk to catholics and protestants and
jews this i mean i i i talk to them and
try to understand people from all over
the country what what's possible
and um i i believe that there is a
uh that people looking at
sort of the cliff that that were you
know that america is just hurtling
towards this cliff and about to go over
i i think an awful lot of people
protestants catholics and jews and
others
would be
willing to negotiate some kind of a
a
return of
let's say the
the basic christian moral vision to be
like the public background against which
uh things are are operate in some places
i mean in some some states in the us and
i think
the conservative way to do this is you
know not to have uh the supreme court
you know dictate this to people who
don't want it the conservative way to do
it is to experiment with it in those
places that want it so that we can see
what is this you know what does this add
up to instead of like you know saying
well you know
christians were always terrible
throughout their history let's see what
the chris which i don't believe by the
way but instead of that kind of like you
know argument in the air we should do an
experiment let's see let let's see what
you know
what does a what are the christians in
america when they get to be like the
public culture in uh in in a few states
what do they do if
if it's better and i i'm guessing it's
going to be better if it's better so
people want to move there and other
states will adopt it and and if it's you
know as terrible as you know everybody's
always saying to to let the you know to
to let the christians where they're a
majority to have that let them have the
public if it's so awful so we'll see
that it's awful and we'll say okay we
tried that that didn't work let's do
something else
so do you see something like what's
going on here in florida where i think
we're defending almost everything you're
talking about but not from the religious
perspective in that the governor is not
up there talking about this stuff from a
religious perspective however he's doing
a lot of the work that i think you're
calling for he is acknowledging
differences biologically between boys
and girls and getting rid of critical
race theory out of the schools and he's
fighting against the constantly
overreaching federal government all
those things
i think i sense that you still think
that that may not be enough for the
experiment as you want it is that right
no i i i don't think it's enough because
i i mean
the basic problem is that
you know for for many years
most
uh most liberal you know scholars and
professors who talked about this kind of
thing theorists um they talked about
liberalism as a neutral state
like a a state that wouldn't actually
have any kind of moral vision it would
just be neutral and let everybody do
what they want and
this book argues and i mean i'm
certainly not the only one but i'm
arguing there is no such thing as a
neutral state like you could you can try
it but it it it just it continues to be
mostly you know mostly christian values
up until the moment that it just falls
apart and you suddenly realize that it's
you know it's anti-christian
and i think that's what's happening you
know that that's what's happening in
america and in in britain and other
places too is that um there
there is a public philosophy but that
public philosophy is progressive woke
neo-marxism
and
i i i know that there are a lot of good
liberals
who um they they want to hold on to the
idea of well let's just go back to a
neutral state
and i i think they just don't understand
that
that that that's collapsed and the it
hasn't collapsed by ac by accident it's
collapsed because of the fact that
when you're saying no the state is
neutral we don't have to defend any
particular set of values when you say
that then you just open the door for the
marxist to take over the only way you
can fight like a serious uh public
religion or public philosophy is with
another public philosophy if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell